un encuentro de alta atención este
viernes el jefe de la diplomacia de la
unión europea
josep borrell y el ministro de asuntos
exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov
estuvieron en una cumbre decisiva cuando
las relaciones entre ambos están en su
nivel más bajo es cierto que no están en
su mejor momento
nos vemos más como competidores o
rivales que como socios no ha dada la
pala
ambos defienden sus intereses como el
caso del opositor ruso alexéi navalni
uno de los temas más acalorados de la
reunión sobre este punto el jefe de la
diplomacia europea fue muy claro
mi visita coincidió con el arresto y la
condena de alexéi navalni y la detención
de miles de manifestantes
como es de esperar y transmitido al
señor lávrov nuestra profunda
preocupación y he reiterado nuestro
llamamiento a su liberación y a la
puesta en marcha de una investigación
imparcial sobre su envenenamiento o
dagestán y como consecuencia al
tratamiento recibido por naval y la
unión europea se plantea sanciones para
rusia estamos acostumbrados a que la
unión europea recurre cada vez más a
restricciones unilaterales que no tienen
base legal estamos construyendo nuestra
vida sobre la base de que la unión
europea es un socio poco fiable al menos
por el momento
el ministro ruso declaró que su país y
el bloque europeo habían manifestado su
interés en establecer un diálogo más
amplio en los puntos en los que están de
acuerdo como la posible llegada de la
vacuna sputnik sobre el mercado europeo
con un 92 por ciento de eficiencia según
expertos europeos
la vacuna rusa está a la espera de su
homologación de parte de la agencia
europea de medicamentos